hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do a
history video about a character that's
going to play a much bigger role in Game
of Thrones season 7 you're on Greyjoy
most of what we know about Euron comes
from the books so this will contain
spoilers including some from an early
winds of winter chapter that was
released a while back it'll also have
some season 7 production spoilers that I
talked about in one of my earlier videos
so you've officially been more make sure
you stick around to the very end of the
video to learn about the book giveaway I
have for my subscribers with all that
out of the way let's get right into it
Joran Greyjoy is a member of house
Greyjoy from the Iron Islands he was the
oldest of Balin Greyjoy's younger
brothers and that makes him Yara and
Theon's uncle he has a really cool
personal coat of arms which has a red
eye with a black pupil beneath a black
iron crown that's held up by two crows
in the show Euron came on to the scene
in season 6 he showed up and killed his
older brother Balin and then made a
claim to be king of the Ironborn during
the Kings Moon after getting elected he
decides that he wants to do some more
kin slaying but doesn't get a chance to
take yar and Theon out before they leave
the Iron Islands with a large part of
the fleet the show's version of your on
so far is a bit disappointing for book
fans for a couple of reasons for me the
biggest one is that they just haven't
given us that much of his backstory and
that's why I'm making this video he is
definitely a bad dude with an
interesting past with so little time
left the show probably won't include
much of it but it's interesting it may
help you get a better idea of what we
can expect from him there are also some
theories about him which are pretty cool
too which I'll get into at the end since
they're more relevant to his book story
this is what we know about your on from
a Song of Ice and Fire
you're on his pale and handsome with
black hair and a dark beard he wears a
patch over his left eye and his
nicknamed crows eye / Theon the patch
conceals a black eyes shining with
malice he drinks shade of the evening so
his lips are a pale blue you become Yara
was here being Ironborn leaving Ironborn
getting ready to bring us back to glory
and how we should do that I build the
largest fleet the world has ever seen
Wright's idea except I'm the one who's
going to build the iron fleet because
I'm the one who knows how to use it
I've been all over the world I've seen
more of it than all of you combined and
across the sea there is a person who
hates the great lords of westeros just
as much as we do
someone with a large army three large
dragons and no husband I'm going to
build that fleet and I'll go together
man
ride over and give it to Daenerys
Targaryen along with my big [ __ ] the
dragon queen I'm not going to do sir
the iron fleet was to do sir and
together we're going to take the Seven
Kingdoms right away we noticed that show
you're on is a bit different in his
looks he doesn't wear a patch there so
there's no mystery about his black eye
also at least to this point there's no
mention of shade of the evening like we
saw with the warlocks back in the house
of the undying and carve urine is a
wildly unpredictable man known for his
delight and playing vicious mind games
and waging psychological warfare on
anyone around him he's hated by his
brothers for this reason he's a skilled
warrior and manipulator and he's cunning
shrewd and ruthless despite is dangerous
and mercurial nature urine has little
trouble and drawing men to his service
while most Ironborn captains keep the
lion's share of plunder Euron takes
almost nothing for him so that's not to
say he hasn't collected some cool things
in his travels through the east though
he was supposed to have owned a dragon
egg at one point and what we think is a
suit of Valyrian steel armor the most
interesting thing that the show left out
is a horn that is supposed to bind
dragons to as well at the Kingsmoot
Euron promises to conquer all of
Westeros for the Ironborn using dragons
which he claims he combined to his will
with the horn this went down differently
in the show but the result was pretty
much the same in the books he has his
brother Victarion sail to marine to find
an heiress but the show cut that
caracter out completely I don't think
the horn will play a role in the show in
all since we already know that he'll be
teaming up with Cersei in season seven
for the most part but I guess you never
know if the show's version is so
different you might be wondering what
the point of knowing about it is point
is that urine has the potential to be
one of the evilest of bad guys in a show
that's had a lot of them since we got
spoiler information from the watch from
what Watchers on the wall describes as a
reliable source that you're on and
Cersei will be teaming up in season
seven knowing what this character is
based on makes versus a lot of exciting
speculation so what's so evil about your
on just to give you a an idea and this
is not everything here are just some of
the greatest hits or some of the worst
things that he's done he sailed raped
and pillaged all over the known world he
claims to have traveled to a shy and to
have walked the smoking ruins of old
Valyria in the beginning of the Greyjoy
rebellion he put together a plan to send
his brother to Lannisport
to burn the Lannister fleet the plan
worked and they were able to destroy the
westerland's naval force without a fight
your own was banished from the Iron
Islands by his brother Balin for
seducing or raping his younger brother
salt what he was warned never to return
while Balin was still alive his ship or
galley is called the silence because it
screwed by mutes this is believed to be
because you're on cut all their tongues
out it has black sails and his decks are
painted red to hide the blood that
soaked them he has fathered several
bastard children but has no regard for
any of them he claims to have owned a
dragon egg which he was unable to hatch
he claims that he threw that in the sea
but a popular theory says otherwise in
the winds of winners sample chapter the
Forsaken Joran admits to causing the
deaths of two of his brothers as a child
we also found out that he probably raped
his other younger brothers while they
were still young there's a lot more but
I think he get the gist by this point he
is as bad as they come and basically has
no boundaries in the show they've gone
even further on the kink in slang point
as he openly planned to kill his niece
and nephew and no one really seems to
mind also in the show he threw Balin off
the bridge but no one knows if he did
that for sure
because no one was there and in the
books it's likely that he actually
didn't do that now we know Queen Cersei
is no
slouch when it comes to being evil but I
think the combination of these two
together will amount to an evil force we
have yet to see in Game of Thrones
Ramsay was an evil character but if you
think about it no no one else besides
the kennel masters daughter openly
indulge in his insanity with him here we
have a character that is maybe more evil
than Ramsay in the first place and if
that's possible who we expect will be
teaming up with the person who's
currently sitting on the Iron Throne
of course the duo is likely to be headed
for Destruction regardless of anything
else but it could make for some insane
action before we get there so real quick
before I finish I wanted to mention some
of the theories about Euron that have
been going around like I mentioned they
aren't very important to the show story
but I still think they're worth
mentioning the first one is related to
that dragon egg I told you about the
theory goes that he didn't throw the egg
into the sea but instead traded it to a
faceless man as payment for the
assassination of his brother Balaam this
is interesting because in the books we
have a good idea that a faceless man has
infiltrated the Citadel at the same time
Sam's arrived and he could be there to
learn how to hatch the egg I mean if
there's anywhere that it's written down
how to do such a thing that would be
where you would find it the other theory
that has been talked about a lot lately
since the Forsaken chapter came out is
one that I find super interesting since
it involves blood rape the idea is that
when you're on was a boy the three-eyed
crow came to him in his dreams just like
he did with bran he tells his brother
Aaron when I was a boy I dreamt that I
could fly when I woke I couldn't or so
the maester said but what if he lied
this is very similar to what brands
experience was like and a lot of fans
wonder if there's more than coincidence
there there's also a choice of imagery
for his personal coat of arms that bears
a resemblance to all things blood Raven
there are actually a few theories about
the three-eyed crow being in contact
with Joran that are a little bit
different and I won't get into all of
them but I find it likely that there's a
possibility of a connection between the
two characters since so many people have
brought it up if you want to read more
about some of the different theories
just put your own bloodraven in Google
or Reddit and the most popular ones will
come up so that's the quick and easy
history of your on Greyjoy now that you
know more about him let me know what you
think leave a comment
what you think he'll be capable of and
if you think he is the most evil
character that will be in the series if
you haven't seen my production spoilers
video where I talk about the rumors
about the Greyjoy's that came out of the
filming locations for season seven you
should check it out I'll put a link
right up at the top but be warned there
is some epic stuff in it that gives away
part of season sevens story please like
the video if you enjoyed it and make
sure to subscribe to my channel before
you navigate away I have two more Game
of Thrones videos I'm working on that
should both be out before the end of
this week also if you're on Twitter you
should follow my account I spend most of
my social media time there and I always
try to post a lot of interesting stuff
when I hit 18,000 subscribers I'm giving
one lucky fan a copy of a night of the
Seven Kingdoms by george RR martin the
counts been moving fast lately so I
think we're gonna get there soon all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on any of my videos
where I mentioned the giveaway I'll use
a youtube comment picker to find a
winner and everyone will have an equal
chance of winning the book thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon